an der türkischen grenze zu griechenland
ist es zu gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen gekommen
die griechische grenze polizei setzte
tränengas und blendgranaten gegen
migranten ein
die von der türkei an die eu grenze
gelassen worden waren
die regierung sprach von mehr als 4000
illegalen grenzüberschreitungen die
abgewendet worden sein
es sind tausende flüchtlinge die über
die grenze wollen den zaun drücken sie
weg sie wollen nach europa die
griechische polizei beschießt sie mit
tränengas versucht die illegalen
grenzübertritte zu verhindern
es kommt zu gewaltausbrüchen die
menschen an der grenze
sie sind verzweifelt wir sind jetzt zwei
tage hier
hier sind kleine kinder zwei monate alte
babys sie feuern tränengas auf uns ein
mann wurde von einer kugel getroffen
wir haben hier nichts zu essen von
türkischer seite werden die flüchtlinge
nicht mehr aufgehalten
präsident erdogan hat verkündet wir
haben die türen geöffnet heute früh sind
18.000 menschen auf dem weg zur grenze
es können bis zu 30.000 werden wir
werden die türen in nächster zeit nicht
schließen und lassen die menschen ziehen
2016 hatte die eu mit der türkei ein
flüchtlings abkommen geschlossen um den
zug der flüchtlinge nach europa
aufzuhalten
die eu versprachen gegenzug
milliarden-hilfen doch erdogan ist damit
nicht zufrieden
die eu hat sich nicht an ihre
versprechen gehalten wir müssen uns
nicht um so viele flüchtlinge kümmern
und beherbergen wenn er ehrlich und
anständig seid dann beteiligt ihr euch
wenn nicht dann öffnen wir die türen
die lage an der grenze bleibt angespannt
[Musik]